[Musique]
il a rejoint Emmanuel Macron en 2017
mais mon invité n'est pas franchement
issu de la start-up nation élu de
montagne il manie l'humour et
l'autodérision comme peu d'hommes
politiques osent le
[Musique]
faire bonjour Joel Girot bonjour alors
vous siégez à l'Assemblée depuis 2002
d'abord comme apparenté au groupe
socialiste puis au sein du groupe des
radicaux de gauche aujourd'hui au sein
du groupe Renaissance et vous vous
définissez vous-même comme je cite un
T-Rex du Palais Bourbon un T-Rex qui a
développé une technique bien à lui pour
évacuer la pression dans les moments un
peu tendus on vaevoir un extrait d'un
reportage de ma collègue hè Bonduel qui
vous AAZ suivi fin 2019 dans le marathon
budgétaire alors que vous étiez
rapporteur général du budget
AB
quand on jongle avec des dizaines de
milliards d'euros il faut se ménager des
pauses le remède au stress pour Joë GIR
c'est le hard
rock ah ben là on me que ce soir j'ai un
billet pour aller voir je pas à CDC ti
ils sont toujours
bons est-ce que vous avez fait ça juste
pour les caméras de LCP ou est-ce que
vous rédigez vraimentos vos amendements
en écoutant du Ramstein j'écoute du
Ramstein mais j'écoute partout tout le
temps du Ramstein parce que j'adore ça
et d'ailleurs on m'a encore offert à mon
dernier anniversaire ça date de peu de
temps du mois d'octobre du 14 octobre
pour être précis un concert de de
Ramstein à Lyon au printemps prochain
donc vous voyez je je suis fidèle à la
musique métal et au métal allemand en
particulier parce je trouve
particulièrement bon et al qu'est-ce que
vous y trouvez dans cette musique Méal
dans dans Ramstein qu'est-ce que ça vous
apporte bah écoutez moi ça
me voilà je suis à un concert de
Ramstein à lon c'est je reconnais le le
stade de
Lyon ça m'apporte comment vous dire
c'est l'inverse de ce que je suis dans
la vie courante je suis un mec non
violent typique et et en même temps je
trouve que c'est une mélodie avec une
musique qui est assez forte et
engageante et d'ailleurs c'est c'est une
sorte d'exuttoire en un dé plus qu'un
exutoire c'est c'est un ça m'emporte un
bien-être c'est voilà mais
d'ailleurs quand on est pas trop coincé
sur des musiques de de ce type là sachez
que Ramstein non pas dans la version du
clip que vous avez vu tout à l'heure
parce que bon je pense que la la dame
assez dénudé avec un serpent ça ça
passerait pas mais sans ça c'est la
musique qui passe dans tous les temples
protestants allemands et qui est repris
par les chales protestantes donc
finalement vous voyez que c'est final
final B c'est fidèle à mes racines c'est
mais c'est aussi fidèle au fait que il
faut pas avoir d'a priori sur les choses
les gens et la musique alors ce qui vous
différencie de la plupart des député
c'est aussi votre goût prononcé pour
l'humour on vaevoir une courte vidéo que
vous aviez posté sur Twitter en 2018
vous étiez encore à l'époque rapporteur
général du
[Musique]
budget alors la musique qu'on entend
c'est la musique du film Men in Black on
VO avec toute votre votre équipe
débarquer comme ça à Bery au ministère
des Finances ça fait un peu descendre de
police ça faisait des cent de police
mais CEN était une puisque les
prérogatives du rapporteur général du
budget font que on peut avoir un
contrôle sur pièce et sur place et é
allé chercher des informations FC en
espèce j'avais besoin d'information la
direction de la légisation fiscale ne me
les donnait pas j'avais prévenu que si
je ne les avais pas rapidement je
faisais une descente conformément au
texte et j'ai fait la descente j'ai
prévenu quand même les cabinets la
veille au soir mais au petit matin ça a
été une certaine surprise à Bery quand
je fait savoir que si on ne me recevait
pas c'était du pénal donc c'était une
démarche très sérieuse politiquement
vous l'avez mise en scène de façon un
peu humoristique est-ce que c'est pas un
peu risqué l'humour quand même parce que
je crois que cette vidéo sur les réseaux
sociaux elle elle a pas plu à tout le
monde elle a déplu à certaines personnes
dans l'administration euh globalement de
de bers mais également dans
l'administration de l'Assemblée
nationale bon alors au bout d'un moment
on l'a un petit peu enlevé parce que ça
ça faisait polémique mais bon moi je
trouvais que c'était une bonne chose pu
c'est une bonne chose qu'un rapporteur
général euh puisse prouver qu'il est
allé faire son job
contrôler le gouvernement contrôler les
les comptes publics c'est notre job
quand on est rapporteur général du
budget pour en revenir à l'humour on
peut l'util l'utiliser de plein de
façons différentes en en politique vous
l'utilisez dans quel but vous vos
blagues vous servent à quoi en politique
bah d'abord je suis fait comme ça donc
c'est naturel et puis de temps en temps
quand on est un peu roublard j'avoue que
je suis un peu de de temps en temps ben
la petite blague à de balles fait passer
quelques fois des choses qui sans ça ne
passeraiit
pas passer un amendement ça fait voilà
je je VO je l'ai déjà je l' souventu des
ministes avecquel ça ça marchait bien
quand géralmanet était au budget en
particulier on faisait un duo qui qui
était assez assez bon je dois dire sur
ce plan là et l'humour faisait que
finalement l'ambiance dans l'Assemblée
nationale n'était pas tout à fait celle
que vous connaissez aujourd'hui pour les
débats budgétair est-ce que est-ce que
l'humour c'est peut être aussi un moyen
de jauger vos aire voir comment il
réagissent bah écoutez c'est une manière
aussi de déstabiliser certains puisque
quand on quand des gens n'ont pas
d'humour c'est trop sympa de les
déstabiliser en ayant de l'humour voilà
donc c'est une manière aussi de
déstabiliser l'adversaire d'une manière
quand même sympathique alors il y a la
musique métal il y a le goût pour les
blagues il y a aussi votre tenue he faut
savoir que quand on vient vous voir dans
votre bureau il y a une chance sur de de
vous trouver en short en tong et et en
chemisette alors oui tout ça vous
confirmez je vous confirme que je suis
chemisette et pas une chemise à manche
longue VO alors tout ça pourrait donner
l'image de quelqu'un de pas très
sérieux à qui on peut pas forcément
faire confiance sauf que bah c'est pas
forcément laave d'un certain Édouard
Philippe on vaevoir ce qu'il disait de
vous dans
l'émicycle vous avez été capable de
démontrer pendant ces de années et demi
que la très grande connaissance de la
matière financière et budgétaire pouvait
passer par un caractère
truculant
joyeux parfois farceur mais toujours
rigoureux de cela monsieur le rapporteur
général je veux vous remercier au nom de
l'ensemble du gouvernement alors cet
hommage c'est au moment où vous passiez
la main de ce poste de rapporteur
général du budget on vous sent presque
ému là l'image on vous voit oui je le
suis ouais non je le suis parce que
d'abord parce que Édouard Philippe n'est
pas quelqu'un qui fait des des
compliments facilement à tout le monde
la question était posée à Gérald
hermanin et c'est lui qui a décidé de
répondre c'est complètement ça et parce
que j'ai apprécié justement le
personnage son côté extrêmement sérieux
qui cache quand même je vais dire
presque de la tendresse et là c'est vrai
que c'était moi qui étais déstabilisé
parce que je ne m'attendais pas à à un
éloge de de cette nature qui montre que
on peut faire de la politique
sérieusement sans sans se prendre au
sérieux c'est quand même la la bonne
solution sans ça sans ça vous rendez
compte depuis le temps que j'en fais de
la fais de la politique je me serai
quelque peu ennuyer alors vous avez un
parcours politique assez riche mais
j'aimerais qu'on revienne un peu sur sur
vos débuts euh parce que vous étiez
parti pour faire carrière dans la dans
la haute fonction publique et puis en
1989 vous êtes présenté pour devenir
maire d'Argentière laabessé c'est un
gros bourg des Hautes Alpes dont vous
êtes originaire vous dites que c'est un
peu au nom de votre père que vous l'avez
fait pourquoi complètement mon père
était maire de cette commune et cette
commune a subi un désastre absolu qui
est la fermeture d'une usine péchinée
mon père en est mort il a eu un premier
ABC en 85 un second en 86 parce qu'il
voyait tout ce pourquoi il avait
vécu disparaître quoi euh donc oui je me
suis présenté parce que je au nom de mon
père parce que je pensais qu'il fallait
euh prendre le relais derrière lui pour
reconstruire un avenir à la commune
qu'il n'avait pas eu le temps de mettre
en œuvre et est ce qu'il avait largement
fait disparaître voyez ces images qui
étaient enfin moi je me RPP j'ai chial
enfin j'ai chialé al moi j'ai chialé
quand j'ai vu l'usine pas quand j'ai vu
l'usine tomber là c'est les ouvriers qui
chal parce que c'était leur lieu de
travail c'est la cheminée c'était
vraiment le symbole et mais tous les
gens qui ont vécu dans des endroits
industriels dans dans les bassins minier
ou cérurgique du Nord et de l'Est ont le
le même sentiment c'est un sentiment de
de tragédie vous avez vraiment
l'impression que tout s'arrête ou alors
il y a chez vous une vraie fierté à
venir d'un territoire rural c'est
d'ailleurs votre principal moteur en
politique défendre la ruralité face aux
normes imposées par par la capitale et
c'est quelque chose qui remonte à loin
je crois que vous l'avez av même
manifesté le jour de le premier jour de
votre arrivée à Lena ben oui je l'ai
manifesté parce que nous avons été reçu
si vous voulez de manière séparé à
l'époque il y avait les élèves du
concours interne les élèves du concours
externe il y avait les élèves issus de
l'école nationale supérieure des postes
et técunication ceux de la ville de
Paris et on ne recevait pas les gens en
même temps alors moi j'étais à la fois
du concours interne et de la filière
pour C Télécom donc j'étais plus rural
que les autres et le directeur des
études nous a dit qu'il conviendrait
tout de moins de point trop exhiber
notre ruralité j'ai trouvé ça absolument
lunaire donc je me suis levé je me suis
gratté les fesses et j'ai pris la porte
parce que je je peux pas je peux pas
supporter cette espèce de regard
parisien absolument insupportable qui
qui en plus n'existe dans aucun autre
pays d'Europe il y a que la France où on
a une telle une telle coupure entre la
capitale et le reste du monde c'estàd la
province en 2020 vous êtes passé du côté
parisien on vous a nommé au gouvernement
au poste de secrétaire d'État à la
ruralité est-ce qu'avec ce poste
finalement vous êtes pas retrouvé au aux
manettes pour résoudre tous les
problèmes pour lesquels vous vous étiez
engagés en politique cé un peu le poste
dont vous deviez rêver non bah c'était
le poste dont je rêvais c'est très clair
d'autant que d'autant bah d'autant que
la ruralité incluait la montagne donc
pour moi c'était assez important B le
bilan écoutez il y avait 181 mesures de
l'agenda rural qui avait été décidé du
temps justement d'édard Philippe et Jean
Castex et le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron m'ont demandé de les
mettre en œuvre et je les ai toutes
mises en œuvre une par une et j'en ai
même rajouté deux parce qu'on ne parlait
ni d'égalité hommes-femmes ni d'égalité
des droits LGBT euh en milieu rural donc
j'en ai rajouté deux il y en av 183 et
puis je crois que j'ai fait le job
d'ailleurs les territoires le
reconnaissent plutôt alors vous avez
part parlé de ce que vous avez ajouté
sur les droits des LGBT en milieu rural
euh c'est un dispositif pour aider en
gros les les jeunes gay qui se
retrouvent mis à la porte de chez eux on
va dire par leurs parents quand leurs
parents n'acceptent pas leur
homosexualité c'est complètement ça ça
c'estement ça avec j'ai une question
assez personnelle là-dessus est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous avez vous
vécu dans votre histoire familiale non
j'ai pas j'ai été rejeté par personne
donc par vous avez une phrase bon j'ai
une phrase effectivement ça plaisait pas
énormément à mon père voà vous AZ confié
dans Libération il n'a jamais accepté de
voir un mec dans mon pieux voilà bon ça
c'est vrai que mais je connais peu de
pères qui acceptent ce genre de choses
pour être franc mais mais c'est vrai que
voilà mais ça çaen est arrêté là mais je
veux dire dans la société après j'ai
fait une carrière politique secret de
poli Finel euh c'est même pas la peine
de j'allais dire de de l'exprimer ou ou
d'en rajouter je suis je ne suis un
militant de rien et tout cela ne doit
pas être un un sujet à mettre sur la
table pour quoi que ce soit si ce n'est
pour éviter les discriminations ce que
j'ai fait en tant que ministre en tout
cas aujourd'hui vous l'assumez
publiquement vous voit tous les ans à la
marche des fierrtés rurales dans la
Vienne ici chevauchant une licorne
arc-en-ciel les autres députés avaient
mis les avaient mis l'écharpe bleu blanc
rouge j'ai j'ai é un peu moins vous avz
pas le même look non j'avais pas le même
look mais mais la Licorne a survécu
c'est ce qui est
important bon on va on va on va conclure
par notre notre quiz à présent vous
allez pouvoir compléter les les phrases
que je vais vous que je vais vous
proposer vous êtes prêt oh prêt allez on
y va le jour où je ne blaguerai plus je
serai mort ah oui clairement c'est c'est
tellement dans votre ADN que ah oui je
je n'y arriverai je n'y arriverai pas de
je dois blaguer temp je narrive pas
autrement moi président de l'Assemblée
nationale et bien moi président de
l'Assemblée nationale euh je
rassemblerai vraiment les forces vives
de l'ensemble des des mouvements
politiques pour essayer de trouver à
l'allemande un certain nombre de de
consensus je je je crois que ça peut
être fait enfin un peu de Ramstein dans
l'hémicycle
h ça serait une ça serait un grand
bonheur et ça je crois décrisperit pas
mal l'ambiance merci beaucoup Jo GIR
d'être venu dans la politique et moi
[Musique]
merci